welcome to this video playing fonso fan
from the plan Alfonso low enters ro from
the UK at least snuke a flag and let's
try something else try the blue thought
gambit he goes no ok so we may be
transposed to a the ciliate can head
shock time nope is he protecting see
form no yeah this is in fact they're
quite promising porn sec in order to
play for something whiter probably needs
to play that way only recently I had
this in a blitz game and I lost terribly
I remember that
a three queen bee 694 that's also evil
young white has excellent development of
course and the light squares are are
weak oh I didn't think about that means
it could be could be a problem maybe
Bishop d8 maybe push up the area
allowing a queen retreat to e7 now White
has a very clear compensation for the
pawn
but not much that I can do about that at
the moment where to go I think I still
want to go here not to worry seven
because of the the Queen exerting slight
pressure against the night yeah he's
given me another pawn on v2 yeah I'm
taking that taking that not because of
greet also because of treat but I want
to pre prevent be form
okay if knight c6 night be seven maybe
hard to develop without that 96-97 takes
rook takes I broke the aid of rock the
eighth this is very important yeah White
has very good composition it's clear
still I have got two pawns two pawns
assault so very different 221 pawn as
you can quite often just return part of
the material time yeah I'd still have
four haven't I the pond ok so maybe
Knight to Knight b6 s his ID n what
about 9 24 9 p-6 sloppy head is this so
terrible like rook t4i maybe Bishop c6
ok ok i'm falling too far behind on the
clock me to increase the speed
it's not so easy to play against some
yeah maybe fif really okay I now I need
to do something concrete only here
traveling d 8 and deform
Wow yeah I don't have enough time to
really am it's much easier to play for
white with this big initiative okay this
is a violent trying to get the the
bishop out it might backfire terribly
possible
what this is probably some Mouse Club
look at one white resigns hmm yeah very
mysterious how do you may be who I try
to figure out why I played how Brooke a
one is a mouse lip maybe he just click
he has got the script there's this
function the smart move function if you
click on a square only one piece can go
to it it moves to the square maybe
clicked on a one what is this position
actually slightly better for black
according to the computer Wow yeah very
a very difficult position always maybe I
did a good defense job and not not worse
in any position your computer wants to
play a 5 is still very ugly but it seems
that I didn't didn't spoil anything you
now night d 5 is the way this is what I
expected because after this is godrick
b6 quite funny and they are probably I
need to do that anyway yeah no idea
what's going on here completely
mesmerizing position all those pieces in
one clump yeah no idea yeah this is just
the blundering everything maybe he just
clicked on a one and he has got this
Martin who function activated so quite a
disappointing finish to this interesting
game I hope you enjoyed it anyway thanks
for watching